Prof: Okay,
so we're at the conclusion of
our theoretical study of bonds
and reactivity,
then we'll go on to something
completely different,
and we're ending by talking
about reactivity in terms of
four functional groups,
and you're doing your own
functional groups,
remember, for tomorrow.
Okay?
So we already talked about
carbonyl last time.
And now we're going to go on to
amide, carboxylic acid and alkyl
lithium, as other functional
groups.
And then we'll do something
just completely different,
for the next quarter of the
semester.
Okay, so resonance is HOMO/LUMO
mixing that happens
within a molecule.
The molecule,
of course, knows all about it.
It only becomes
"resonance"
because we draw a picture
that's too simple,
and we need to modify the
picture -- right?
-- and that modification is
called resonance.
And a good example of that is
the amide functional group.
Now when I include an amide on
the first exam where people are
supposed to identify functional
groups,
circle them and name them,
it's inevitable that some
people will circle the C
double-bond O and say that's a
carbonyl group,
and some people will circle the
nitrogen and say that's an
amine.
But an amide is not an amine,
and it's not a ketone,
or a carbonyl group.
It's its own thing.
And the reason is that those
interact with one another in a
way that makes them no longer
like an amine,
and no longer like a carbonyl
group.
That's resonance.
So we'll look at it here in
terms of two different pictures
of the molecule.
One is as a carbonyl amine,
and the other is as an amide,
which if you're into Lewis
structures you draw with a
double-headed arrow and show two
resonance structures.
And in the carbonyl and amine,
you identify a HOMO that makes
the thing a base,
and a LUMO that should make it
an acid.
But resonance can be thought of
as a reaction already within the
molecule, between the HOMO and
the LUMO.
And it's a make-and-break
situation,
just like we saw between
molecules last time,
where the unshared pair makes a
new bond --
in this case the second of a
double bond --
and something leaves from the
carbon that's being attacked.
The thing that leaves is the
second bond of a double bond.
So it's another one of these
make-and-break situations.
But in this case,
it's a correction to our
naïve, localized picture
that we drew at the beginning.
Okay, so let's see about this.
First we have the naïve
prediction,
what that should say about the
characteristics of the molecule,
and then what the experimental
observation is,
which requires that we use
something more complicated,
the resonance structures or
thinking in terms of molecular
orbitals.
Okay, so the amines and
carbonyls are perfectly stable
molecules in terms of being low
energy.
They don't just do something.
But what's associated with the
idea of resonance structures is
the thing is more stable than
you would've predicted if you
didn't consider the resonance
structure.
So you say that's more stable.
And you can see why it would be
more stable, because the
unshared pair is mixing with a
vacant orbital and becoming
lower in energy.
In fact, the observation is
that it's more stable by about
16 kcal/mole,
which is about a fourth as much
as a carbon-nitrogen bond is
worth.
So it's a significant amount of
energy.
Now, if you have a C-N single
bond,
that's longer than a double
bond, and longer than a partial
C-N double bond that you'd have
for the average of the resonance
structures on the right.
And in fact that bond is
shorter than normal single
nitrogen-carbon bonds,
by about 0.14 Ångstroms.
Right?
On the left you have a short
double bond for C double-bond O.
But on the right it's a partial
single bond.
So it should be longer,
not held as tightly.
And in fact it is longer than
other C-O double bonds,
by about 0.03 Ångstroms.
Okay?
We've seen before,
when we were talking about
XH_3,
why nitrogen tends to be
pyramidal,
so as to give
s-character to the
unshared pair of electrons.
But on the right,
if it's going to be part of a
double bond it has to be planar.
And we can see why that is.
So here's the Ï€*
LUMO,
of the C double-bond O,
and here in front is the
unshared pair on nitrogen,
in a p orbital,
which overlaps and delocalizes,
mixes, with the vacant LUMO.
Right?
That means that you have a
partial double bond for the C-N,
and a partial single bond for
the C=O.
How is it that putting in
electrons makes it a single bond
rather than a double bond?
Why would putting in electrons
weaken a bond?
Alex?
Can't hear.
Student:  Antibonding.
Prof: Because it's an
antibonding orbital,
the Ï€* of C-O.
Okay?
Now, so it's planar,
indeed -- and I'll show you
pictures that prove it --
because it gives the best
overlap.
If there were an sp
hybrid on the nitrogen,
the s part of it
wouldn't overlap with the
pÏ€.
So a pure p orbital
gives the best overlap.
So that's why it's planar,
from the molecular orbital
point of view.
Now, if you have a single bond,
it's easy for things to rotate
around it, because it's
cylindrically symmetric.
But we know that a Ï€
bond is not cylindrically
symmetric;
it has that oval shape.
So there's a barrier to
rotation about the central bond
of a carbon-carbon double bond.
Because when you rotate the
nitrogen in front,
like this, by 90º,
you've wrecked the overlap that
allowed those electrons to be
stabilized.
Right?
In fact, once you've done this,
there's no reason for the
nitrogen to be sp^2
hybridized anymore,
because the unshared pair is
not trying to overlap with the
carbon p orbital behind
it.
Right?
So it might as well hybridize
and become sp^2 the way
it normally does.
And this structure,
the halfway-rotated structure,
turns out to be 16 kilocalories
less stable than the one where
you do have the overlap.
So twisting it has a barrier of
16 kcal/mole.
Have you ever seen that number
before?
Zack?
Student:  Yes,
at the top there's one.
Prof: That's what we saw
at the beginning.
It's more stable when those
electrons can be stabilized,
as compared to an amine and a
carbonyl that are not
interacting.
Because when you turn it
90º, they indeed are not
interacting, because they're
orthogonal.
Okay, an amine,
as we said, should be basic,
and a carbonyl should be acidic
because of the low LUMO,
the Ï€* C=O.
But if they mix with one
another, then the HOMO is lower
and the LUMO is higher.
So they're not reactive anymore;
they're not as unusual in their
highness and their lowness.
Right?
So it turns out that an amide
is relatively unreactive;
relative to what you'd expect
for an amine and a carbonyl.
Now do you know where you
encounter amides all the time?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: You can touch an
amide, with no problem.
How?
Sophie?
Student:  Part of amino
acids.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  They're amino
acids.
Prof: Amino acids,
which make proteins.
Amino acids aren't amides.
But proteins,
which are made of amino acids,
an amine reacting with a
carbonyl, those are amides.
And you want them to be stable.
Why?
You don't want them to be
reactive, like a carbonyl and an
amine.
Student:
>
Prof: It's so your skin
works.
Otherwise, in lab if you --
what does a base -- if you feel
sodium hydroxide -- you've done
this -- what does it feel like?
Student:  It's slippery.
Prof: It's slippery.
If amides weren't unusually
stable, then when you felt it,
your skin would go away.
Right?
So it's a good thing.
In fact -- and the last thing
is also important.
So they're opposing dipoles,
mostly, right?
Carbon to oxygen is plus
towards carbon,
minus toward oxygen.
Carbon nitrogen,
plus toward carbon,
minus toward nitrogen.
But mostly those two are
opposed to one another,
and a little bit they add.
So you get a net displacement
of positive/negative charge in
the molecule,
from left to right,
positive to negative.
Okay?
That's what would happen if it
were a carbonyl and amine.
But it's not a carbonyl and
amine.
It's strongly dipolar,
not cancelled,
and it's in this direction,
perpendicular to the original
direction.
Because you take electrons that
were on nitrogen in the amine,
and you shift them into the
carbonyl group.
So it's as if -- the magnitude
of that effect,
is as if you transferred
one-third of an electron from
nitrogen to oxygen.
If you did that,
you'd get as much displacement
of charge, on average,
as there actually is.
Right?
Now, it turns out that all
these latter properties are
crucial for structural biology.
We already saw that if you want
skin to work,
it has to not be as reactive.
But these other things are
important too.
The geometric things;
that nitrogen has to be planar
and that there's a barrier to
rotation is very important.
And also the dipolarity;
the direction of the dipole is
very important.
And we'll show that.
So here's an amide bond.
Okay, the nitrogen is blue,
and the oxygen is red.
You see the double bond.
But you shift electrons from
the nitrogen to the carbonyl
group,
and that is the Ï€* --
pardon me, that's the HOMO,
not the Ï€*,
it's the HOMO -- the
Ï€ electron pair,
which has shifted from nitrogen
and shared with the C double
bond O.
Now, that sharing,
as we just said on the previous
slide, creates an electric
dipole.
So the electrons are shifted in
the direction shown.
And that's crucial.
Because here is a picture of a
helix, an Î±-helix of a
protein, and I outline the
backbone of it there.
Okay?
So several turns of an
Î±-helix,
which has a lot of amide bonds
in it.
And if we look at it,
we see there's an amide,
there's another amide,
all more or less on the top of
this helix.
What's interesting about those?
Andrew, what's interesting
about the set of them?
How are they lined up?
Do you think it's favorable or
unfavorable, the way they're
lined up: plus,
minus;
plus, minus;
plus, minus, in a row?
Student:  Favorable.
Prof: They're all lined
up so as to be attractive to
another.
So that stabilizes this
structure.
In fact, another way of talking
about it is to say,
as shown here by these
Î´s,
that the oxygen is partially
minus,
and that the hydrogen attached
to the nitrogen is partially
plus.
So getting this minus near that
plus is favorable.
What do you call that?
Anybody know?
That is a hydrogen bond. Right?
So you have -- it's stabilized
by electrostatic interaction,
these hydrogen bonds.
Not only there,
but there are other ones too,
like here, a chain of them
there, and another chain down
here at the bottom.
So this helix is stabilized by
the fact that the dipole points
the way it did.
If it pointed in the
perpendicular direction,
you wouldn't get this
stability.
Okay?
And it's also stabilized by the
geometry that's favored,
the local planarity,
the fact that you don't twist
around the C-N double bond,
the partial double bond.
So here's carbonyl,
here's the C-N,
and that's -- although it's
written as a single bond,
it's partially a double bond.
So you don't twist about it.
So this atom,
this atom, this atom and this
atom are all in the same plane.
Right?
And you see another such group
here, back behind,
where here is the bond in
question.
So this atom,
this atom, this atom,
this atom are all in the same
plane.
Or here at the bottom you see
it, where you're looking almost
in the line -- in the plane.
Right?
And what does that mean?
It means that the backbone is
not as floppy,
because you take away some of
the possibilities of twisting
it.
So it helps it take this shape.
So both the dipole,
and the geometrical freezing of
some of the single bonds,
means that this structure is
particularly stable,
and therefore very prevalent in
biological macromolecules.
So that makes a lot of
difference, that amides are
amides and not amine carbonyls.
Okay, now how about carboxylic
acids?
That's the next functional
group.
So compared with what are these
acidic?
Compared to alcohols.
Because you might think that,
in the same way that an amide
is an amine ketone,
you might think that a
carboxylic acid is an alcohol
ketone.
But it's not. Right?
They interact with one another,
in much the same way.
Now, if you had just a regular
old alcohol, it can dissociate
as an acid.
It's not very strong as an acid.
You don't burn your skin with
it.
Right?
So it has a pKa of sixteen;
the dissociation constant is
10^-16.
That's not very impressive.
But for a carboxylic acid,
the reason it's called an acid,
is because its pKa is much
lower, it's more acidic.
The equilibrium constant is
10^-5.
So it's acidic,
it's not an alcohol.
It's 10^11 times stronger than
an alcohol.
Right?
Now why?
Well just like an amide,
you have an unshared pair on
the O-H oxygen,
which could be stabilized by
the Ï€* orbital of the
C double-bond O.
Now, if that stabilizes the
material on the left,
how should it affect the
equilibrium constant?
Should it be more or less
acidic?
That is, because of this
interaction,
because of this resonance
structure we could say,
because this pair of electrons
is stabilized by the carbonyl,
there's a factor that's
stabilizing this,
which doesn't exist in the
alcohol.
So you're stabilizing the
material on the left of the
equilibrium.
Would that tend to make it more
acidic, or tend to make it less
acidic, if it's stable on the
left?
Prof: Right?
So you have -- here's the stuff
on the left, here's the stuff on
the right.
It's uphill in energy.
No matter what you're talking
about, it's hard to dissociate
as an acid.
Right?
So I make this more stable,
which is what I just showed.
There's resonance here that
stabilizes this HOMO/LUMO mixing
within the molecule.
Does that make it more or less
easy to dissociate?
Harder or easier?
Student:  Harder.
Prof: Harder. Right?
It's further uphill.
So this seems backwards.
The analog of the stabilization
we saw in an amide that makes
your skin not dissolve,
has the opposite direction.
It predicts that the
dissociation would be more
uphill, where in fact it's less.
Why?
Because if we look at the
product, you also have HOMO/LUMO
interaction, between an unshared
pair on this oxygen and the
carbonyl.
And that will stabilize it on
the right and make it easier to
dissociate.
Which should be more important,
the amount of extra
stabilization on the left?
Here's what it was for an
alcohol, originally.
We stabilize it on the left and
we stabilize it on the right.
Which is more stabilized,
the carboxylate or the original
alcohol - the carboxylic acid.
What do you know from the fact
that it's more acidic;
which must have gone down
further?
Student:  That one.
Prof: This one must've
gone down further.
Can you see why?
Why would this one be more
stabilized by HOMO/LUMO mixing,
that is, this be more
important, than it is here,
with that?
Lucas?
Student:  Symmetry.
Prof: No.
Becky?
Student:  Because of bad
charge separation.
Prof: Okay,
there's bad charge separation
here.
Here, on the right,
you don't separate charge.
That may have been part of what
Lucas was trying to say.
But there's another way you can
say it, just in terms of
HOMO/LUMO mixing.
The language you're using is
the language of resonance --
right?
-- that you don't want to
separate charge.
I want to see why,
in terms of molecular orbital
energies, or atomic orbital
energies, that you get more
stabilization here.
Alex?
Student:  There's an
electron pair that moves into an
antibonding --
Prof: Right,
but that's true in both cases.
There's an electron pair here
that mixes with a vacant
orbital.
There's an electron pair here
that mixes with a vacant
orbital.
Why is it more effective here
than it is here?
Claire?
Student:  Just guessing,
but if the resonance,
for the two structures on the
left,
when the resonance comes down
to the O-H bond it's
anti-bonding.
But with the other one,
because the H isn't there,
it's actually making it more
stable.
Prof: I'd have to think
about that awhile.
But I want you to try again,
in terms of the -- what makes
HOMO/LUMO mixings good?
What makes them important?
Student:  If there's a
higher one over.
Prof: Overlap.
Student:  Overlap.
Prof: That's the same in
both cases.
It's the same oxygen reacting
-- mixing with the same double
bond.
And what else?
Student:  If there's a
high HOMO --
Prof: If it's a high
HOMO.
The HOMO here is an unshared
pair on oxygen.
Student:  Right.
Prof: The HOMO here is
an unshared pair on oxygen.
Are they the same?
Student:  No,
because the HOMO on the left is
taken up b hydrogen.
Prof: Right, okay.
So the one on the left has
another proton,
which this one doesn't.
That means that the electrons
here are more stable,
lower in energy.
And this is a higher HOMO,
which is associated (another
way of saying the same thing)
with the fact that that's a
negative charge.
When you have a negative
charge, it's a bad place to put
electrons.
They are high in energy.
Another way of saying it,
and the way you said it,
which is probably a better way
of saying it,
is that the proton is gone,
so it's not stable.
So you expect more HOMO/LUMO
mixing here because of better
energy match than on the left.
Therefore, the observation,
that it's 10^11 times stronger
as an acid.
So it's a higher HOMO,
because of that negative
charge, or the absence of a
proton.
Okay, so there's our carboxylic
acid.
And finally the last functional
group we wanted to talk about
today, which is a really
complicated one.
It starts very simple,
but you'll see it gets pretty
baroque pretty soon here.
So it's methyl lithium.
And the chance of your figuring
all this stuff out ahead of time
is about zero.
Right?
So don't be depressed if this
looks like it's getting very
complicated.
Remember, there are three
approaches here.
One is to draw lines,
à la Lewis,
to understand how things come
together.
Another one is to use a
computer to generate molecular
orbitals;
to break the total electron
distribution into orbitals and
look at them one at a time.
And having seen what the
computer produces,
some of those orbitals are
interpretable;
as we've seen,
that they're antibonding in a
certain region,
bonding in a certain region,
and so on.
But the chances of your
competing with the computer in
drawing accurate molecular
orbitals --
to the extent that molecular
orbitals are real --
the chance of your competing
with the computer is not very
good.
So don't expect that you can
exactly draw them.
But if you see the one that the
computer has drawn,
at least in some cases you can
make some guesses about it.
You can see how many nodes it
has;
whether there are nuclei in the
middle of lobes,
which would make that a stable
orbital;
where it's bonding;
where it's antibonding.
Those kinds of things you can
analyze, even though you can't
produce them yourself.
So don't think that you're
going to be able to.
Right?
But then there's another point
of view, which is to look at
localized pairs,
bonds and antibonds,
and how they'll come together.
Right?
And that you can do.
That's the intermediate between
using just Lewis and doing the
full molecular orbital kind of
thing.
This is something you can do in
your head, and that's what we're
going to show,
these different points of view
with this one.
So here's methyl lithium.
Now what will make methyl
lithium reactive?
What's a high HOMO of methyl
lithium?
Marty?
What makes HOMOs -- what makes
for a high HOMO?
What kinds of things do you
think about?
Student:
>
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  Like what the
outlines on the slide were
before, unshared pairs and --
Prof: Just with a pair
of atoms.
I'm not trying to make like our
slide before where you're doing
all the complicated stuff.
But just you have two atoms and
they come together.
Will they give a very high HOMO?
What determines how far they go
up and down, the HOMO and the
LUMO?
What's one thing that
determines it?
Student:  Oh,
the overlap.
Prof: Overlap.
Okay.
So here are two atoms that are
coming right together,
to a single bond distance.
So good overlap.
Let's suppose it's the same as
all overlaps.
Okay?
What else?
What is it besides overlap that
determines how far they go?
Student:  Energy
difference.
Prof: The energy match.
Right?
Now what's special about methyl
lithium?
Methyl's not going to be funny
-- that's our standard thing --
but lithium is funny.
Where is it on the periodic
table?
Maybe that's the problem we're
having.
Student:  It's on the --
Prof: On the far left,
which means it doesn't have a
very big nuclear charge.
So does that mean electrons are
going to like being there or not
like being there?
Student:  They're going
to not like being there.
Prof: Because it's not
much nuclear charge.
So it's going to be a bad
energy match,
high energy.
So there's going to be a high
HOMO.
Right?
The HOMO here,
from the carbon,
doesn't go down very much,
because of the bad energy
match.
Okay?
So there's an unusually high
HOMO.
What will it look like?
Where will it be,
on the carbon or on the
lithium?
Student:  The HOMO?
Prof: The HOMO.
Student:  It'll be on
the first one.
Prof: Is it going to be
symmetrical, or is it going to
be more Carbon,
or going to be more Lithium?
Student:  More carbon
because --
Prof: More on the carbon.
That's the lower one.
Okay?
So if we want to look at the
HOMO of this thing,
it's going to be mostly on
carbon, not so much on lithium,
and an unusually high HOMO
because of the lithium.
And there it is,
that's the HOMO.
Marty, you're going to finish
us here by saying what orbital
does it look like?
Student:  It looks like
--
Prof: I'll back up.
There it is and there's the
orbital.
Student:  2 p-ish.
Prof: It's a 2p
orbital on carbon,
mostly.
Right?
With just a little bit of
lithium, 1s,
or 2s,
pardon me, on it.
But just a teeny bit of lithium.
And it's antibonding between
the lithium and the carbon.
It's the -- or no,
no, wait, it must be a p
orbital on lithium,
because it's the favorable one,
it's the bonding one,
right?
We see the blue of lithium,
but there's a little red on the
other side that we don't see,
without making a net,
which I didn't do.
Okay, so that's the HOMO.
It's a Ïƒ.
Now what will the LUMO be?
Kate, what do you say?
What do you think for a LUMO,
of methyl lithium?
Student:  It's going to
be a p orbital.
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  Lithium
orbital --
Prof: Yes,
lithium has a lot of vacant
orbitals on the atom.
Right?
It comes in with only one
valence electron.
Only one of its four valence
orbitals is occupied.
So it's got,
in fact, three vacant orbitals.
So that's going to be a LUMO.
There's the LUMO,
mostly on the lithium.
Okay?
Now, but the LUMO+1 is this
orbital, which I've drawn in a
funny way, at a relatively high
electron density contour,
making the things very small.
Because if I made them bigger
it goes way off the top of the
sheet and off the bottom of the
sheet,
because this orbital isn't held
very tightly by lithium,
it sticks way out.
And it turns out to be out of
the range that gets plotted by
Spartan.
So you get funny looking holes
in the orbital.
So I chose this particular
density.
But anyhow, you see it's a
p orbital,
that's different signs,
top and bottom.
Now, so you have a -- is this
an unusually low LUMO?
Monique, what do you say?
Let me tell you something.
I'd say lithium has a small
nuclear charge,
not a very good place for
electrons to be.
Right?
Which means that it's going to
be a very high orbital energy.
Can you see any contrary things
that say it might be unusually
low?
Student:  I would think
it would be high.
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  I would think
it would be high.
Prof: Because of the low
nuclear charge?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Compared to what?
What are we comparing with,
to say whether orbitals are
high or low?
Student:  To a Carbon or
H.
Prof: The carbon-carbon,
or carbon-Hydrogen
Ïƒ and
Ïƒ* bonds.
Right?
So clearly enough the carbon
and hydrogen start lower in
energy than the lithium does;
but what?
But they have big overlap.
So Ïƒ* is quite
high, much higher than lithium,
because it's an atomic orbital,
it hasn't mixed with anything,
this one.
Okay, so methyl lithium has an
unusually low vacant orbital and
an unusually high occupied
orbital.
And what do you expect?
Prof: You ever seen a
case like this before where the
same molecule was --
Student:  BH_3.
Prof: BH_3,
for exactly the same reason,
right?
Except more so,
because lithium is more so than
boron, being further to the left
in the periodic table.
So we can put two of these
things, above,
up and down from one another,
like this, and have the HOMO of
one be stabilized by the LUMO of
the other.
Kevin?
Student:  Sorry,
could you please explain again
why it has a low LUMO?
Prof: Yes.
Because it's an atomic orbital.
It's not a molecular orbital,
it's not a bonding orbital.
It didn't mix with anything.
The things we're comparing with
are not carbon and hydrogen,
which are in fact lower than
lithium.
It's the Ïƒ and
Ïƒ* bonds of carbon
and hydrogen which --
and this, the LUMO here is
higher than that of lithium --
lithium's unusually low --
because it's still an atomic
orbital,
it didn't mix with anything.
Okay?
So there's stabilization of the
Ïƒ by the
Ï€.
But at the same time we can go
the other way and the HOMO on
the top can be stabilized by the
LUMO on the bottom.
Same as in BH_3, giving B_2H_6.
Okay, so these things dimerize.
They come together,
HOMO of one stabilizing the
LUMO of the other,
and vice-versa.
They move together,
and you get a thing that looks
like that, very much like
B_2H_6_.
Right?
So you have two vacant lithium
orbitals, stabilizing the
unshared pair of carbon.
You can think of it that way.
And it also goes the other way,
the unshared pair on that
carbon is stabilized by two
vacant lithiums.
Okay?
So these are three-center
two-electron bonds;
just as in B_2H_6.
Okay now, but remember,
lithium has two other vacant
orbitals, each atom.
We've only used one here. Right?
So they can combine to give
this.
This is actually the LUMO of
that dimer.
Right?
Those are in the plane of the
four-membered ring.
Right?
And there are other vacant
orbitals too,
like this Ï€ one,
which is in and out from that
four-membered ring,
made up of p orbitals on
the lithium.
That's the LUMO+1,
of that dimer.
Okay, now I'm going to rotate
this.
Now, pay attention here because
the next picture's a little
confusing.
I'm going to rotate this thing
so that we're looking just a
little bit --
we're looking mostly in the
plane of the molecule but
twisted a little bit,
so we can still see the top of
the molecule.
And we're going to twist it
such that the red lobe in back
is behind the red lobe in front.
So what we're going to do is
rotate around that axis and
shift it a little bit toward the
center of the picture.
So it's that same orbital.
And there it is now.
But it's a little confusing in
the middle because there's one
red lobe in the back and one in
the front.
Okay?
We could draw it down -- okay,
so that's what it is.
But we're going to drop an axis
that goes right through the
middle of that parallelogram.
Okay?
And now along that axis we're
going to bring up another
molecule.
But it's going to be rotated
90º.
So those are the same two
orbitals, LUMO+1 in both cases.
The one on the bottom is
rotated 90º
around the axis I drew.
Okay?
Now will those things interact
favorably with one another?
First, they're orthogonal.
And second, even if they mixed
you wouldn't care.
Why?
Prof: Because they're
vacant.
So what we want to do is look
at the bottom,
not at LUMO+1.
We want to look at the HOMO of
that one, that dimer,
which looks like this.
And now you see something neat,
that the blue in front overlaps
the blue vacant one,
and the red in back overlaps
the behind red vacant one.
So the electrons in the HOMO on
the bottom get stabilized,
by overlapping with the LUMO+1
on the top.
And, of course,
by the same token,
the HOMO of the one on top
overlaps with the LUMO of the
one on the bottom,
like that.
So we already had two molecules
come together to form dimers.
Now we're having two dimers
come together to form a
tetramer.
Yoonjoo?
Student:  Why are we
using LUMO+1 on the right?
Prof: Ah,
because that's the one that
does the overlap.
The actual LUMO doesn't overlap
this one on the bottom.
Okay?
Lucas?
Student:  Does that make
the LUMO+1 essentially the new
LUMO, because it's more
stabilized?
Prof: Well,
but it mixes with this one.
So the LUMO+1 and this one
interact.
Here's the HOMO.
Student:  And they make
it better --
Prof: LUMO+1.
So it contributes to this one.
Right?
When the HOMO here,
of the dimer,
mixed with the LUMO+1,
of the other dimer,
you've got a mixture.
This one looks mostly like the
HOMO of this dimer.
But it's a little bit helped
out by looking like the LUMO of
this one.
There's a new vacant orbital,
but it's still higher.
You don't care about that one
anymore.
Okay, so now we can take two of
these and bring them together.
That's a bonding,
the orbitals we just showed.
And you get a cube. Right?
So here's the one on the
bottom, one, two,
three, four;
and here's the one on the top,
one, two, three,
four.
And they've been turned
90º, to line up these
orbitals, and they come together
and the electrons get more
stable.
Now that used,
on every lithium,
another one of its vacant
orbitals.
Right?
But what Angela?
Student:  There's
another one.
Prof: There's another
one.
Okay.
So the HOMO now turns out to be
this.
And you can understand that,
the biggest part of it,
by seeing that it's a
four-center, two-electron bond.
Mostly it's a p orbital,
or a hybrid orbital of the
carbon,
an unshared pair of carbon,
but it's stabilized by three
vacant orbitals of lithium.
So three vacant lithium atomic
orbitals stabilized the unshared
pair of carbon.
But, as Angela points out here,
there's another one.
That's still a vacant orbital
on lithium.
That's on the top lithium.
There are other ones on the
other three lithiums.
So we need more electrons -- or
it's capable of stabilizing more
electrons.
Where do you get them?
Well you might think you bring
another cube up.
But in fact there's something
easier to do,
because this is done in
solution, and the solvent is
dimethyl ether,
as shown here,
or some other ether,
which has an unshared pair of
electrons,
and it comes along and gets
stabilized by that.
But at the same time the other
three oxygens,
the other orange balls -- the
other three lithiums I should
say -- stabilize oxygens of
other ethers.
So you have four ether
molecules associated with a
tetramer of methyl lithium.
And this is about as complex as
we're ever going to get.
Right?
So I think you would've had a
hard time, at the outset,
predicting this.
But having seen it,
I think you can understand it.
That's what we're aiming for at
this stage.
Because as we go on and get
lore, that this reacts with this
and gives this,
what I want you to be able to
do is to look at it and say,
ah ha, that's what happened,
that's why that reacted that
way.
In some cases you'll be able to
predict.
But in other cases you'll be
able to understand and correlate
it with what you know.
So if you put more ether in,
if you have a lot of excess
ether, then it rips these things
apart.
So it can fly apart and you get
a bunch of ethers on every
lithium.
All right?
And in fact this is a further
development of organic
chemistry,
beyond what we usually do in an
elementary course,
which is to understand the
non-bonded interactions.
Because often you wouldn't
consider that oxygen-lithium to
be a real bond.
It's just sort of a weak
solvation thing;
although truly it is a bond.
Okay?
So these so-called non-bonded
interactions and the effects of
solvent are a vital part of
lore, what solvent you choose
for a given reaction.
For example,
if you want to facilitate
ionization, you use certain
solvents and not other solvents.
And we'll talk about that a
little bit.
But I just want to show you
what there is out there,
beyond the bonding that we've
already talked about.
But we've really taken theory
pretty far here,
in the first half of the first
semester of the course.
Now, I said we would vote.
And I forgot to bring a piece
of paper.
I have this piece of paper,
but I'm not going to use it for
that, because this is the thank
you note.
So if you want to -- if you
haven't signed it -- why don't
you pass it around?
Because there are a few people
who haven't signed it.
Let's pass it down,
back and forth,
down the aisles.
I think most people have signed
it, but some haven't.
You don't have to.
And you also don't have to
contribute.
But if you want to be -- have a
sense of satisfaction of having
contributed to the class gift,
you can leave a small coin on
the table over there.
Okay, but the other business we
have to transact is I'm going to
give a review session before the
exam.
But it's not obvious when we
should give it.
So I've decided that the
easiest thing to do is to see
how many people cannot -- of
course we want people not only
that can, but would come.
Right?
If you could come but wouldn't,
you're irrelevant.
So the question is,
how many people cannot -- or
would come, other times,
but cannot come at the time
shown?
And the one that has the fewest
will win.
That make sense?
Okay, so how many people cannot
come Thursday evening,
8:00?
That's too many.
How many at 8:30?
Here we have about,
my judge is about fifteen.
How many cannot come Friday
afternoon?
Student:  Lab.
Prof: Whoa!
Okay.
How many people cannot come
Saturday, early?
That's a lot.
How many Saturday at 10:00?
How many Saturday at 2:00?
How many Sunday, 1:00 to 3:00?
Students:  Too early.
Prof: Well bear in mind
that there's also the TA session
Sunday evening.
I think it's better if I do it
two days before the exam,
rather than the day before.
But on the other hand,
none of these earlier times can
get -- they're always at least
fifteen people.
Well let me see about option
two.
That was the one Thursday at
8:30.
How about if it were 9:00?
How many could not come if it
was at 9:00?
Student:  Wait,
which Thursday?
Prof: Thursday evening,
tomorrow evening.
That actually is -- and let's
see Sunday again,
Sunday, sometime early
afternoon.
There are actually more who
can't come on Sunday than
Thursday.
So I'm sorry,
but it'll be Thursday.
It could be 8:30 or 9:00.
Does it make a difference?
Is there somebody who'd come if
we started at 9:00?
Student:  Is Saturday
one?
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  Is Saturday
one?
Prof: Saturday what?
Student:  Is Saturday
bad?
Like how bad was that?
Prof: Saturday was
pretty bad.
But let me see, Saturday 9:00?
Yes, that's worse.
Saturday 10:00?
Saturday 2:00?
Saturday 8:00 p.m.?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: So it'll be
tomorrow night at 8:30,
and I'll send you an email,
once I got a room.
Okay, let's continue.
Okay, so to summarize the first
half of the semester.
We've seen amazing modern tools
that show us molecules,
the real thing,
at the level of Ångstroms
and at the time scale of
picoseconds,
10^-12 seconds.
We've seen scanning probe
microscopy that can feel atoms,
and X-ray diffraction that can
see them, and can see bonds,
with difference density.
We've seen spectroscopy,
IR and ESR.
And next semester we'll talk
about nuclear magnetic
resonance.
So there are amazing tools,
not only experimental tools,
but theoretical tools.
This stuff about quantum
mechanics so that --
and people believe quantum
mechanics enough that they talk
about doing calculations on a
computer as
"experiments,"
rather than just things you do
in the lab.
So that's amazing. Right?
And it all has developed fairly
recently,
say since the time -- most of
the important things we've
talked about have developed
since I was in graduate school.
But what's amazing is that
organic chemists were not at all
surprised when they were finally
able to see these things.
Because they already knew what
they looked like.
So it wasn't surprising.
It was satisfying.
And there were a few little
queer things that are understood
better now than they were
before, certainly.
Right?
And things like being able to
generalize about what makes a
functional group,
that's completely new.
Right?
But fundamentally what
molecules look like and how
atoms behave and that this
reacts with this,
that was already known.
So how could they possibly know
it when they didn't have these
tools?
And that's going to be our
chore for the next quarter of
the semester,
is to figure out how they knew;
how did organic chemistry
really develop?
And a reason for this is that
if you know how it developed,
then you understand the
language much better.
Because the language we use
isn't the language of quantum
mechanics usually.
It's the language that
developed during this long
gestation period.
And it started,
as we said before,
in the seventeenth century.
And we've gone on this,
and we've talked now about
science,
the scientific method and force
laws,
and how we finally found out
what the force law was for
atoms.
Right?
And in the twentieth century,
this whole theoretical,
experimental stuff came
together and we saw that bonds
were shared electrons,
and we could see them,
and that quantum mechanics
could help us to understand
them.
But we've left out this middle
period,
starting with the end of the
eighteenth century,
with Lavoisier discovering
oxidation,
and ending with the discovery
of quantum mechanics.
Because this is the period
during which most of organic
chemistry developed,
and we have to see how it
happened.
Okay?
So this, if you'd been here 107
years ago, and been graduating,
you would've been in this
picture, with your fancy boots
and so on.
Right?
This is the Computer Science
Building.
You walk up now -- it used to
be the Chemistry Lab,
on the right.
You know where it is?
Watson Lab down there.
Okay.
So let's look at some,
see what they understood at the
time.
They chalked things on the
bricks, to show off their
knowledge.
So here's CH_4 methane;
obviously they knew that.
And here's the reaction of
sulfuric acid with zinc,
which gives hydrogen;
they knew that.
And here, what do you think
that crazy thing is in the
middle?
Student:  A benzene ring.
Prof: That's a benzene
ring.
And remember how it looks like
what they confirmed at about the
same time?
The clairvoyant people saw that
the valences all went to the
center.
Okay?
And down here you see another
thing.
Those are probably aromatic
rings, with the double bonds not
shown.
But an interesting thing that's
shown, the Greek letters,
Î± and
Î² there.
Those are symbols that are
still used to denote different
positions that you can put
substituents in the ring.
Okay, this is inside the
Chemistry Lab,
which was where SSS is now.
And you see things like this,
right?
Which came from that lab I'm
sure.
There was a big box of them
floating around here,
and I rescued one of them a
long time ago.
The others got thrown out.
There.
And what's that second arrow?
There's another important tool.
Student:  Bunsen burner.
Prof: The Bunsen burner.
Right?
Bunsen invented the burner
about 1860, or something like
that, or '70.
Okay, here, there's one that
looks just like this,
right?
Actually, this isn't that old,
because it says on it
"West Germany".
>
Prof: Okay,
there, what do we see here,
the white thing?
Student:  Mortar and
pestle.
Prof: Mortar and pestle;
they could grind things up.
Right?
And there, what's that?
Student:  It's a burette.
Prof: It's a burette
drying upside down.
Notice, that's the only
quantitative tool.
So were there any other
quantitative tools in this
picture, that they were showing
off?
Student: Well there's
somebody who has it on the side.
Prof: Ah ha,
there were burettes.
Anything else that will give
you a number?
Student:  A scale.
Student:  There's a
scale.
Students:  Oh.
Prof: But that's just a
crude balance,
right?
There had analytical balances,
but they weren't portable,
they couldn't schlep them out
to Prospect Street,
for the picture.
Okay, but that was it.
Okay?
This guy here.
>
Looked like that;
C. Mahlon Kline, Class of 1901S.
And you know his name because
GlaxoSmithKline.
And he gave money for the Kline
Biology Tower,
and the Kline Chemistry Lab;
and the Kline Geology Lab too.
But you could also measure
angles on crystals.
Right?
But that's about it.
Somehow, with these tools,
they figured out where atoms
were, in molecules.
Isn't that crazy?
So if you look at the front of
the building,
you see down here -- he's
wrapped in stuff now because
they're painting him --
Benjamin Silliman,
Yale's first scientist;
first chemist anyhow.
And he's holding something.
Can you see what he's holding?
Student:  A crystal.
Prof: A big,
whopping crystal.
Right?
That's where science was at.
That's what he's mostly known
for, is mineralogical things.
Okay.
But here, on these plaques,
is something else.
This is the names of the people
who actually developed all this
stuff, during the nineteenth
century.
So it starts in the seventeenth
century, actually,
with Boyle and the gas laws.
But that was way before --
notice, he was born 120 years
before the time we're talking
about, Lavoisier.
So things happened,
but not a lot,
for our purposes,
during that period.
And it really got underway with
the second person.
These are in chronological
order.
The second one was Lavoisier,
and that's where we're going to
start.
And then Gay-Lussac,
Berzelius, Faraday.
We're going to talk about these
people.
Okay?
And here is you,
and your cousins,
who did all this stuff.
Because we have a family tree
here.
So there's you, and me.
And I studied quantum mechanics
as a graduate student with
E.B. Wilson -- right?
-- who was a post-doc with
Linus Pauling at Caltech,
who did X-ray and proteins.
He's the first guy that saw the
helices of the proteins.
Okay?
And another post-doc of Pauling
was Jack Dunitz,
who we've talked about a lot.
So Dunitz, who we've talked
about a lot, is your
great-uncle, academically.
>
But if we go back -- oh,
and here are things -- notice
how many of these things,
the twentieth century things
we've talked about.
Notice that boldface is things
that are experimental,
and normal face is theoretical
things.
Shared-pair bonds,
mesomerism, which is resonance.
Electron pair shifts,
the curved arrows.
Quantum Theory.
Reaction mechanisms;
we already talked about ammonia
being oxidized by chlorine,
for example.
IR spectroscopy we talked about.
We haven't talked about -- well
we've talked a little about
polymers, not much.
We haven't done mass
spectroscopy.
Well we did actually the
problem set in the first thing,
right?
Conformational analysis we'll
do at the end of the semester.
X-ray we've talked about.
NMR, next semester.
Molecular orbital methods,
we've talked about a lot.
This is what we've been talking
about.
That we'll do at the end of the
semester.
Non-covalent structures we just
talked about a little bit.
Scanning probe microscopy is
quite recent,
and so on.
So we've actually talked about
a lot of this stuff already,
the more recent stuff.
But what we want to talk about
now is the earlier stuff,
how people discovered things in
the nineteenth century.
So these are the guys that did
it.
And in particular we're
starting with Lavoisier.
But Lavoisier was not the first
altogether.
But I'm going to have to wait
'til next time to tell you who
was first.